are you guys enjoying the show you I did
you that show I played a creep called
Henderson and uh let's talk about it a
little bit you know when you're on a
show a real show like I've done a lot of
comedy shows but when you're in a real
show with real acting and real actors
and good actors and good production and
good writers and [__] and people that
give a [__] about it you know
it's so funny to be a comedian on one of
those shows because
look people are I'm really happy that
people are liking what I did you know a
lot of people are saying a lot of really
positive things about my performance and
I really appreciate that and I want you
to know something I know I know
I know I'm gonna go in there and [__]
do it at least okay
okay do you know why I know because I
got a good head on my shoulders all
right I'm not gonna go in and [__] some
[__] up yeah I played in the scene where
he had to torture me and [__] stab my
arms a little bit
and I'm really getting into that
[__] dude
do you understand
I don't act I'm not [__] dude I'm not
gonna act in it I'm I I believe I'm a
[__] crazy [__] you
understand I sit there and I think okay
dude I'm getting tortured let's do this
[__]
you understand I'll cry right now dude
I'm I don't these [__] where do
I put okay so if I walk it actors is
What actors do so if I walk in all right
you want me to grab the thing see that's
the thing I gotta grab the phone and
walk over here that's what happens when
a director says hey could you maybe say
that over here that's what happens when
an actor gets that note oh you gotta go
uh uh oh okay I gotta well let me uh if
I go over there though that I need to
take the phone because the phone and you
want me to already have the phone over
here then that's bro no no no no no when
a director says hey could you say that
over there I go like this okay and I do
this [__] and if it doesn't match in the
[__] that's your problem bro I don't ask
these questions because I'm really doing
it bro
I'm not asking about props can you put
the shirt on sure fine did it make sense
in the edit I don't give a [__] I'm here
to do
you know is Henderson from you based on
a real person kristalia plays an awful
dude [__] yeah I do because they asked
me
you know
oh it's the the two dumbest things that
people are
oh I get involved bro
when I do it when I do it I've seen I
get involved man you understand me
huh dude
you'll you'll never see me act bad dude
you won't [__] see it okay
um
so
so uh
I was in so the two things that people
are saying
what the [__] is crystalia doing in you
bro acting man that's how I do it
and here's the other one
hey crystalia keeps playing a [__]
pedophile
twice
name another time dude
two times I played a pedophile once in
you and the other when I was on the show
Whitney and that's [__] dude
you can't name another one
it's that's so annoying when people say
that
because dude
somebody wrote do you intentionally play
pedophiles or do you what hey what they
asked me to be in the [__] thing I
liked the part so I said yeah
foreign
all I'm trying to do is get to the point
where I can be an action star and then
also in the end of my career like the
Liam Neeson years I can play a Japanese
guy with no makeup
that's my dream bro is to [__] up the
internet and just play a Japanese guy
with no makeup and have people just
irate about it
well why didn't they get a real Japanese
guy to do that well because Chris Delia
is a big star you know when I'm 60. and
we thought he was going to get the
[__] box office
and I did because and I want to get
nominated for a Golden Globe and that's
it no Oscar dude just the Golden Globe
and not win
and all they do is straighten my hair no
makeup
and I barely use an accent because I'm
so subtle dude
and I'm not acting
while I'm filming
I'm Japanese crazy crazy crazy crazy
[Music]